Speaker 1: It's hard to believe, my friends,
but Donald Trump glitching badly at a recent
speech in Washington, DC suggesting more
crimes if he were to be elected president of
the United States a second time. This was again
at some kind of religious event in Washington,
D.C. over the weekend. Here, Donald Trump says
if he becomes president, he will deny entry to
the United States, to communists and Marxists.
Is this potentially legal? I'll tell you in
a moment. Listen to what the failed former
president. Twice indicted, twice impeached,
had to say to a disgusting sycophant crowd.
Speaker 3: Made them competitive. Today,
I'm announcing a new plan to protect the integrity
of our immigration system. Federal law
prohibits the entry of communists and
totalitarians into the United States. But
my question is, what do we do with the ones
that are already here that grew up? I
think we have to pass a new law for them
using federal law in section. 212 f. Of
the Immigration and Nationality Act. I
will order my government to deny entry
to all Communists and all Marxists while.
Speaker 1: Quite an idea.
Speaker 3: Those who come to
enjoy our country must love our country. We
want them to love our country. We don't want
them when they want to destroy our country.
Welcome to America. We want to destroy your
country. Thank you very much. So we're going
to keep firing Christian hating communists,
Marxists and socialists out of America. All right.
Speaker 1: So you get the idea. Keep communists,
Marxists and socialists out of the United States.
Also equating being a socialist to hating America.
There's many socialists who like America in the
same way that there's many people who think gun
laws should be more permissive, who like America.
Just because you want something to be different
doesn't mean you hate America. But what Trump is
proposing is almost certainly against the law and
impossible. From a practical perspective,
it's against the law because Trump's idea
would violate the First Amendment of the United
States Constitution. It protects freedom of
speech, religion, press, assembly and petition.
Communism and Marxism are political ideologies
that people have the right to express
and they have the right to believe in
them as long as they are not advocating for
violence or an overthrow of the government,
they are allowed to believe those things. It is
also against the law because it would violate the
equal protection clause of the 14th Amendment,
which prohibits discrimination based on race,
ethnicity, national origin or other arbitrary
criteria. Communism and Marxism and socialism are
not inherent traits of any ethnic or racial group.
They are movements and they are quite complex
movements, by the way, which have followers from
different backgrounds in different countries.
It's impossible from a practical perspective to
do this because there is no clear or objective
way to define who is a communist or a marxist.
There are many different branches and schools
and interpretations of communism and Marxism. Some
are contradictory, some are incompatible with each
other. And there are also many people who just
like one aspect of communism or Marxism. Like if,
for example, are you a communist? If you want to
nationalize the airlines, I don't know. You can't
come to the US on that basis. Are you a marxist?
If you believe in the labor theory of value,
doesn't make any sense, and that's why it's
impossible. From a practical perspective,
how can you reliably screen or monitor
people's political beliefs at the border?
And do you think for a second that those who say
government's incompetent, everybody's incompetent,
they now want to deputize Immigrations and
Customs Enforcement to quiz individuals about
the political beliefs and determine if they are
communistic, socialistic or Marxist. It's insane
and ridiculous and almost certainly against
the law, which makes it a perfect proposal
for Donald Trump. A couple other clips from
this ridiculous speech. Trump also said that
on day one of his presidency, he will again
try to ban trans people from the military
and heavily.
Unidentified: And on day one,
I will reinstate the Trump ban on.
Speaker 3: Transgenders
in the.
Unidentified: Military. We
added that. If there's a
worry, you should be focused
on crushing American enemies.
Speaker 3: When being strong,
on having the image of being strong. They have to
be powerful. They have to be strong, especially
when you see what's happening in the world today.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So, first of all, as usual,
the biggest applause line during Trump's entire
speech, when it was when he said he would ban
trans people from the military. Think of how crazy
that is, though. Men are allowed in the military.
Nobody denies that women are allowed in the
military. I don't think anyone denies that. Even
though there are people on the right who don't
like that. So why would you ban trans people if
men and women are allowed in the military? Why on
earth would you ban trans people? And of course,
we have a number of studies about this, and
it makes no sense to ban trans people from the
military. Trump did the entire thing about, yes,
I'm a victim, but really, this is about you saying
he is being invited for them, whatever that means.
Speaker 3: Every time the radical left, Democrats,
Marxists, communists and fascists indict me,
I consider it a great badge of courage. Okay.
I'm being indicted for you. And I believe the
U. Is more than 200 million people that love our
country. They're out there.
Speaker
1: As as usual. We don't know exactly what these
numbers mean. 200 million people. Trump has said
he has hundreds of millions of supporters
in the country, but he doesn't. Certainly,
even if you assume that he has twice as many
supporters as the number that voted for him,
that still puts it at 150 million or under. And
I think we all know that the number is actually
quite small, much smaller than that. But this
is part of the grift, the way he grift money on
indictments, which he's doing. Well, maybe we'll
look at some fundraising emails he sent. Maybe
we won't. We probably won't, actually. I'll just
tell you, he's sending out 50 fundraising emails,
and part of the reason that he's doing it is he
has come up with this storyline of they're really
going after you when they go after me. It's part
of the victimhood complex. And then lastly here,
Trump again misstating the law about classified
documents claiming he just does no crime and he
could do whatever he wanted with the documents.
Unidentified: Phony case. Well, it is true.
I mean, it is true that.
Speaker 3: In other words, whatever documents
the president decides to take with him, he has the
absolute right to take them. Really, he has the
absolute right to keep them. Or he can give them
back to Nara if he wants. He talks to them like
we were doing, and he can do that if he wants.
That's the law. And it couldn't be more clear.
Speaker 1: Okay. So as Democratic Congressman
Daniel Goldman explained on Twitter, this is
an argument that should be blocked from even
being made during Donald Trump's trial because
it is a false representation of the law. One of
the things you're not allowed to do in a defense
is to misstate what the law is. The judge will
instruct the jury as to what the law is and the
special counsel prosecutors will likely move to
preclude Trump from making this argument in court
because it is simply not what the law says. This
is a tough argument that Trump is making. This is
a PR argument. This is a grift argument that Trump
is making. It is not actually what the law says.
So another weekend, another completely unhinged
and dangerous speech from the failed former
president. Let's now look at what's happening
with polling in the 2024 Republican primary